بعد جولاته حول العالم ومشاركته في اهم
المهرجانات السينمائيه منصه نتفليكس تعرض
الفيلم الاردنيه الحاره الفيلم سبق وان
حصد عددا من الجوائز المهمه من جائزه
الجمهور في مهرجان ما الموسمين
من ملتقى القاهره السينمائي للافلام
الروائيه ضمن فعاليات مهرجان القاهره
السينمائي الدولي تدور احداث الفيلم
مع حبيبته الفيلم الاردني الحرم التاليف
واخراج الغندور بطوله
الفيلم الحاره حصل جوائز مهمه لكن اثار
الجدل شو سرها الجدل
اثار عندما تقدم الحقيقه
احنا صرنا نقدم اشياء ما بتشبهناش
اظن الان
اليوم منذر
الناس تقول والله خطر وانت رايح تصور
خريبي ليش شو الي دفعك
ليبيا ابو سيدي عمر المختار قبل الشهداء
فات بحس انه من واجبنا ان نقدم نقدم شيء
ااا دليل او الاهلي ليبيا في ظل الاشياء
اللي اللي قدموها لنا
ليبيا جميله
وحسيت واجب انه الفنان يحارب
بمادته وكنت مبسوط جدا
من حيث تجرب العظيم جدا همم
ورجعت منتصرا من ليبيا عشان اهل ليبيا قدم
محمد رائع همم بيننا فيه انجازات
هو كمان انجاز لانه الفيلم الثاني فقط بعد
عمر المختار يكون الانتاج الليبي 100%
في عندك مهرجانات يقدم الفيلم الاول باذن
الله في المهرجانات العالميه همم دائما
نحنا بنحكي لا ننتمي الى السلاح ننتمي الى
الكلمه ولكن هم اجبرونا اللي همم
متخلفين والدواعش
حكايه انسانيه في خريبيج كتابه اللواء
خالد المحجوب
بطوله مجموعه كبيره من النجوم كلنا
متحمسين
جداول
بمشروع بناء من جوانب مختلفه واظن نحن بس
احسن من الشهداء اللي قدمنا في سبيل الوطن
احدث التصريحات بتقول فيه انك بتبحث عن
ادوار الصعبه ليش الادوار الصعبه تحديدا
تلاقي فيها متعه وهل ادوار الشر هي المتعه
بالنسبه لك كتمثيل
لا انا بحب اقدم الشيء المختلف شوفي مهما
كان انت
موجود في الدراما في في كل التاسيس يعني
ولكن شو الاسلوب
في الموضوع مش موضوع انك بلعب او دور خير
في موبايل بالنسبه
البياني ابداعه في ماده التنفيذ هي صعبه
جدا لانه عنده كثير يعني مبررات مختلفه
واشياء مختلفه جدا انا بحبش اكون محادث
نعم